what on Earth is happening on Twitter
Elon Musk seemingly completely losing
control of whatever changes he's trying
to implement now apparently just taking
polls on his Twitter account to decide
major Twitter policy reversing a
controversial policy in which linking
out was not allowed it's completely
whacked what's going on and this is not
a very professional way for running such
a major social media platform but I
don't think that's going to come as a
surprise to too many so one interesting
first note on December 18th Elon Musk
tweeting should I step down as head of
Twitter I will abide by the results of
this poll
17 million people voted I voted yes it
seems bad that he's running Twitter and
indeed 57 percent said yes he should
step down 42 said no now Elon Musk I
don't think is so stupid that he would
do this without knowing the likely
outcome and without already planning to
step down I I think maybe hope to some
degree
as of this moment he has not clarified
whether he will indeed step down but it
doesn't seem like he has any idea what's
going on and it does seem that he should
step down additionally Twitter has
deleted a controversial new policy
Banning links to other social platforms
which we're going to talk to we're going
to talk about more detail in a moment
and I'll tell you what I think
ultimately is going to happen with
Twitter first let me briefly tell you
about our sponsor
Masterworks this has been a wacky year
for investors and markets retail
investors are down an average of 30
percent this year billions lost it's
completely Bonkers I have started to
expand my asset allocation to other less
traditional assets many non-traditional
assets can outperform other Investments
there's one asset that's seen a 17
increase in sales in the last year even
as the s p is down about the same amount
and that's Blue Chip r art Fine Art if
you want to invest in Blue Chip art
Masterworks is the platform to do it you
can invest in artists like Picasso
Banksy Monet Warhol now you might say
how can I do that sir I can't buy a
Monet that's crazy the way it works is
that each painting is qualified with the
SEC which I've linked below Masterworks
has over 600 000 users over 650 million
dollars worth of art if they sell a
painting you've invested in you get a
slice of the return because you're only
buying a slice of the painting this is
how without being able to afford an
entire painting you can invest in Fine
Art the most recent sale was November
for about a 13 return to investors
before that there were sales at 17 and
21 return art is lowly correlated to
stocks and bonds which potentially means
it's a hedge against inflation and art
markets tend to perform better during
periods of inflation there's a wait list
to sign up you can skip the wait list at
masterworks.art Pacman and using the
link below and remember none of this is
investment advice for any particular
person I'm telling you generally about
asset allocation options that are out
there should they be appropriate for you
now what's going to happen with Twitter
Twitter has deleted its controversial
new policy Banning links to other social
platforms that makes sense it was an
insane idea to begin with CNN reports
Twitter deleted its controversial new
policy on Sunday evening that banned
links to certain other social media
platforms less than 24 hours after the
initial policy introduction this came
shortly after company owner Elon Musk
launched a Twitter poll asking whether
users think he should step down as head
of the platform
um there was huge backlash to this
policy and it really doesn't make sense
users were being prohibited from
tweeting links to in some cases Facebook
Instagram Mastodon and Truth social
truth essential right
um it also deleted a tweet thread from
its Twitter support account that
announced the policy earlier in the day
here's the bottom line on Twitter it's a
mess
it's a mess and it's such a simple
analysis Elon Musk is in way over his
head Elon musk's personal motivations
and personal priorities have taken
precedence over so much else including
the best uh operational approach to
Twitter
properly working with employees in a
human resources capacity moderation it's
a complete and total mess Elon Musk
should step down I am listen he bought
the company he owns the company
um he should be forced to sell no that
doesn't make any sense but for the
betterment of the platform and
everyone's experience someone else
should be running it and uh people have
written to me and said do you think
Twitter will be bankrupt in a year no
the thing about Twitter is to the extent
that it maintains a use user base in a
certain level of tweet activity it has
significant inherent value so even if
it's not worth the was it 44 54 billion
that Elon Musk paid
it's not going to go bankrupt maybe it's
worth 20 billion and someone else will
pick it up for 20 billion in a year that
is a much more likely scenario than it
goes bankrupt and completely shuts down
if you disagree with me on that let me
know down in the comments